joining us now Lieutenant Colonel Oliver
North Colonel North let's get your
assessment I want to go back to the same
line of questioning I had with secretary
Pompeo I understand the need for
Intelligence on the ground and even
boots on the ground for Israel however
if you know where the network of tunnels
are why not use military sophisticated
new military technology and take out as
many of those tunnels as possible from
the air and not risk a ground incursion
where like our troops in Iraq we didn't
have this technology you know are going
to be stepping over IEDs every other 10
feet or
so well first of all Sean Israel's
attack plan is much more sophisticated
than it's coming across on in the media
the campaign in Gaza isn't just one
point of entry it's all along a 30 mile
long border there are zones of action
prep fires they're clear have to clear
buildings then clear entire city blocks
and they're going to shoot back that's
the Rules of Engagement that they've got
return fire they're going to do
everything in their power to avoid
inflicting civilian casualties they've
got devices and they've got Munitions
that are not widely known that they're
going to use in those tunnels there's
ways in which you want to make sure that
you're not good Lord forgive if all
those hostages were banded up in one
long tunnel that got attacked by Israel
that would we'd pay for that for decades
so what I'm what we're looking at is a
situation where the these guys know what
they're doing what I'm more concerned
about are the questions us the good
secretary and and I'm glad he's on with
you because he's a dear friend and I
have enormous respect for him but what
took place in the 7th of October that
took the lives of at least 30 amets
could not have happened but for Iran if
they turn hez balah loose from their
bases in Lebanon and Syria to attack
Israel it should not come as a surprise
that Iranian built missiles whether
they're fired from Iran or from Lebanon
or from God forbid Gaza that they will
be soon be firing at US Naval Assets in
the Mediterranean the President should
immediately tomorrow morning announce
all existing sanctions against the
regime in tyan will be immediately
enforced and he's going to have to
immediately lift his own self-imposed
shutdowns on fracking and Drilling and
reassure the American people we're not
going to run out of fuel and by the way
refill our strategic petroleum reserves
number two if Hezbollah attacks Israel
the US will hold the Iranian theocracy
responsible and act with devastating
effect to prevent further threats to us
personnel and assets number three the
President should also direct the US
Department of Justice to indict the
terrorist leaders like yaha sinir and
Hamas head of state isma Hanya the
so-called Hamas foreign minister for
killing at least 30 American citizens
ever since the 7th of October and though
we don't have an extradition agreement
with gutter an interpole posting of
those guys faces in airports around the
world might keep these thugs from tra
traveling freely around to the whouses
that they're known to visit number five
he needs to order the National Guard to
secure our Southern border immediately
number six notify the Iranians that if
Hezbollah attacks Israel we will shut
down Iran's entire oil export capability
that's one of the things that the
secretary was just referring to much
more diplomatically than I did that
should make all those who are filling
the ayatollah's coffers with billions as
you pointed out will bring some pressure
to bear on tyan for example Beijing
might just pick up the phone and say hey
guys knock it off we need your oil and
finally we ought to offer our CC in
Cairo US Air Traffic Control and
Logistics assistance to open a major
secure Refugee facility and humanitarian
food water and medical support facility
near Al arish International Airport in
Gaza I've been there I I've I've I've
seen this this in Sinai rather just
south of Gaza and that border crossing
could become an enormous Refugee Center
in which we get the biometric data on
every Refugee waiting to Avail
themselves Avail themselves of food
water medicine and shelter and the kinds
of things that were trying to ship
across the border and Hamas is stealing
that's it colel you you were on my shows
so often post 911 we spent a lot of
personal time for me it was some of the
the getting to know you being being a
best friend of yours was like a dream
come true for me I grew up admiring you
it's one of the reasons I got in this
business and we spent a lot of time
together I didn't like a lot of the 9/11
Commission report didn't agree with it
didn't think it was firm enough but they
got one thing very very right they were
at war with us we were not at war with
them we have been witnessing literally
tens and tens and hundreds of thousands
of rockets fired into Israeli cities it
has been going on for year after year
after year we've known about this
network of Tunnels for quite some time
if if the takeaway way from the 9/11
commission was they were at war with us
we weren't at war with them what part of
these Rockets fired into Israeli cities
and this network of tunnels built to
kill and capture Israelis um was not any
indication that they were in a
full-fledged war against Israel why did
it take October
7th we are still the great Satan the
little Satan is the Israel that they
want to destroy first that's number one
number two we have allowed particularly
since the Obama Administration and now
certainly in this Administration the
Iranians to get away with all kinds of
terrible things and the secretary was
wise to point out and remind everybody
that we took out the architect of what a
lot of the Islamic revolutionary guard
Corps and the ks Force have done around
the world to make
enemies of ours able to carry out
attacks on Americans that's that's the
kind of leadership that we desperately
need back in Washington
all right Colonel North stay with us
we'll get back to you throughout the
evening as well hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else